[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kitten and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
and a fascinating person we have for you
today he is a returning guest to
trigonometry
he's one of the co-authors of the
grievance hoax papers
he's the man who's read all the critical
race theory
books that so you don't have to james
lindsay welcome back to trigonometry
i'm glad to be here especially after
that introduction
james before we we start mate i've got
to say you may have read all the books
but more importantly did you post them
to your instagram story
no i actually can't figure out how to
use instagram i have one
and i like get these messages and i know
how to reply to people and that's as far
as i got i haven't figured out how to
post anything yet
when you do make sure you post the black
box because that's how you stop racism
now it is this is wait right
that's what it means symbolic action is
everything
well listen uh we spoke with you
probably about a year ago i'm guessing
we you you guys were in london we we had
a very interesting chat with you and
peter pagosian
at the time i think the interview that
we posted then was called
social justice is a mind virus i'd say
we're all pretty [ __ ] infected at
this point um
is that is that a fair assessment of
what's going on here
well uh yeah it's it's uh really spread
pretty quickly
um it's uh mainstreamed
at an incredible rate since uh the death
of george floyd at the end of may
uh and now i mean i
basically can't find anybody outside of
kind of the old people
who don't talk about it all more or less
all the time and
uh obviously if you look at what's going
on in like the media
it's just become like a blatant circus
of lies
where you know oh here's a building
being smashed in and on fire and they're
like whiteness property from cheryl e
harris
you know this is a very important piece
of scholarship saying why you can burn
down also burn down a starbucks or
something
and so yeah um this is a particular way
of thinking
it is in a sense contagious and the
contagion of moral
values sense people are are brought into
thinking this way because it leads them
to feel like they're a good person
rather than somebody who's failing to
live up to goodness
and it has very very rapidly
uh spread it has very rapidly become a
dominant if not the dominant contending
moral force that's rising in the western
world and
it is getting exported from there as
well in an
astonishingly short time so yeah um
i mean we have like the perfect metaphor
for what's going on like it was in these
research labs and then
some scientists weren't really careful
with how they disposed of you know
whatever and it got out and then all of
a sudden you know you have to start
closing countries down
and i mean it's it's odd the parallelism
here but yeah it is it has spread very
much like a pandemic
very rapidly and and you know we're now
you know hopefully close to the peak of
the wave uh
because people are starting to talk a
bit differently and james with every
pandemic there are catalysts there are
things that basically speed it up
and what would you identify as a
catalyst is kobe the catalyst or have
there been other factors involved as
well
i mean yeah kovit is probably actually a
catalyst for a number
of reasons one of which is that it drove
us all indoors
and we stopped socializing normally and
we got kind of pent up and frustrated
the fear the uncertainty around
economics that came with it
the lack of normal social interaction
the lack of being able to go out and
blow off steam in the normal ways that
people do
the shuttling everybody into online
communication kind of constantly it's
like there's a feeling that's not wholly
wrong
that this change is like twitter having
just exploded into the real world
and everybody's interacting like they're
on twitter constantly in some sense
and um that makes sense because
everybody's been on twitter constantly
for months and i know that's the case
because i remember when the lockdown
started people were saying
wow i don't really have anything to do
it's like a break and everybody you know
i get
i have it's like a good chance to
remember how to slow down in life and
i'm like my
my incoming crap went up by like
60 because all of the people who are now
two online
or who are not too online before became
too online and started uh
sending me stuff so it's like the amount
of incoming messages and emails i had
went up about 60 once the lockdowns
began
and i don't think that that's a
coincidence people started to act online
there are lots of other
of course catalysts that led to this but
i do think covid was relevant
um obviously there are
shorter and longer term trends within
kind of the
socio-political sphere trump derangement
has been
ramping up for both good reasons and bad
reasons
and i think is a huge contributor to
this and i do mean that trump
derangement
i think there are extremely legitimate
reasons to be very concerned about and
unhappy about
uh president trump but there are also
just
histrionic lunatic responses that don't
match reality whatsoever
and this it's we just mentioned symbolic
action you know joking around but
so much of that like i went to new york
city
last summer and we ended up staying
near trump tower in manhattan and so i
just walked up there just to go
out for a walk one day and i told my
family you know i walked by trump tower
and i saw trump tower and i took a
picture looking up
how tall it is or whatever and my family
was like why didn't you take a picture
of your middle finger pointed at it and
i was like why would i do that
like what does that accomplish in the
world does that like end his presidency
that i flipped off a building
like it doesn't make any sense so there
was a lot of stuff going on with that
and that's part of a longer current if
you look at the anger on the left in
america
with feeling like the republicans have
been stealing our politics
where of course the republicans on the
other hand say they were defending or
politics
from the radical left stealing our
politics so
now it's all kind of very fraught but
these were all kind of antecedents and
catalysts as well but i mean the obvious
approximate cause was that there was
a cause syllabary that came up with
george floyd's death at the hands of a
police officer which was pretty clearly
like way out of the normal acceptable
range of behavior
that everybody said this is you know
proof
that something's wrong which very
rapidly mutated into this is proof
that our entire system is bogus feeding
into a narrative that's been
being laid very effectively for i don't
know seven or eight years now
uh if not longer and i remember you
saying james
uh these clips act as
i can remember you using them almost
like religious icons was i think the way
that you know
miracle stories yeah miracle story so
would you just touch on that because i
think it's very very important
how this miracle story then
became an example of how racism has
effect is it has infected
all our political structures and our
institutions
yeah when you have a um kind of
nation faith coming into into the
picture or even one that's well
established
uh when you have a set of beliefs in
particular
that are i don't want to say just
blatantly untrue it's more that they're
really vague
and so they're they're true and untrue
at the same time by virtue of not really
saying anything specific enough
like our society is systemically racist
what does that mean well it means that
outcomes are different well that doesn't
really tell you anything we already knew
that you know it's very vague or if you
talk about you know
god's love is everywhere well what does
that mean it means god's love god loves
us and it's everywhere you know it
doesn't tell you anything
so a lot of times the way that that that
profession of faith or the the
the the belief is reinforced is by
people
seeking out confro confirmatory uh
narratives or events that are like
miracles so you see you know these funny
stories where you know jesus appearing
on a piece of toast
or you see these things where they see
that you know the sun glare
off of a particular glass window
looking like the virgin mary and so
obviously this is now a holy spot and
there's a miracle and somebody's like
dripping water and saying that's your
tears or something
and they cook up these ideas and in the
ancient world you could really see
you know oh this amazing thing happened
and then they go tell people and there's
no verification whatsoever and so just
the story can get bigger and bigger
and this becomes like yeah the faith is
true because this thing happened
and in our current era we get that
primarily through mediated
clips we get a clip of something that
happened
in the case of the critical race
narrative it has mostly been
clips of people acting in racist ways
that are
usually somewhat egregious or clips of
police officers interacting with
typically unarmed black people that end
up in
a fatality of the black i don't know
what the right word is i don't want to
say
you know perp or suspect or whatever but
the person that they're interacting with
anyway that's
on the other end of the law and
the context of those the full context of
those clips doesn't matter
what matters is
the way that they fit within that
broader narrative
so on when i went on joe rogan's podcast
recently i brought up michael brown
and i i said you know it looks as though
um this was this horrendous killing if
you just watch the video
the police officer is way out of line
and the black lives matter movement
around ferguson
literally went to the point of blocking
traffic and many of the same kinds of
protests and riots and antics that we're
seeing now
and it turned out not to be based on
reality whatsoever
um right because i never got
acknowledged james actually
i remember at the time trying to say to
people
like what you're told about what
happened isn't what happened and right
that's
been verified scientifically it's been
verified medically
it's been it's been by black and white
witnesses
it's been verified by tom and hissy
coates who's like deep in the ideology
that this was not a police murder it was
his statement about it
so yeah that's the thing is these
narratives have the power to run off and
take a life of their own i mean
when you tell somebody that the virgin
mary appearing in the reflection of a
you know car wash window
isn't actually the virgin mary it's just
what the sun does when it hits glass of
that shape
um they tend not to
accept that because it would be
disconfirmatory we want to get into kind
of the psychological and philosophical
thinking behind it it's because when
people have adopted a mythological way
of thinking you can't pick apart a myth
to pick apart one strand of a myth is to
tear the entire myth apart
and to to render it uh not true or not
believable
so you can't look at scientific
validation you can't look at the full
story you can't look at any of these
kinds of things
the more important thing is this
event fits within the context of the
myth and gives the myth
legs and because that narrative is so
powerful
people run with it and it almost can't
be unseated if you were to then go back
and say
um yeah well you have a point you know
the michael brown incident
uh and on joe's podcast i didn't know
and joe kind of pushed back on me i was
like actually i don't know the details
and i come home and i get like 5 000
emails telling me like here's tony hissy
coat saying
and like okay that's good enough for me
um i'll take that
if you know he said it and so it's like
you can't though
look at that and say well we have to now
revise the entire
basis for our movement you instead have
to find a way to reconcile that
cognitive dissonance either by
downplaying it ignoring it
or recasting it in some other more vague
sense that still confirms the narrative
because the point of a myth is
of mythological structure is that
it can't be torn apart it can't be taken
apart and so when you think of these
kinds of mediating events like
our mediated stories about events i
should say
pushing these narratives you have to
think of that
in terms of mythology you have to think
of that in terms of
the the the video the clip the
the the you know snippet of story the
picture or whatever
you have to think about that in terms of
how it fits within the story that's
trying to be told and that people have
taken on and nothing else
is going to be allowed to matter because
that's that and that's also how you know
that
when there's this outright rejection of
any possible criticism of the
foundations of the story
that you're dealing with something
that's gone spiritual and it's all
mythological at that point
well james let's you talk about the
mythology and that's something i'd
really like to
dig into but let's i wanted to ask you
first of all just for anyone who's
watching this and you've brought up
donald trump and
going to the tower and not being willing
to flip it off on camera
just for the sake of appearance and
whatever just very briefly
it may be in the sentence to remind
people where you are politically just so
that
people who don't know you it's really
funny um it's like
apparently twitter has media mediated me
and i'm apparently like a famous racist
now and i'm
all kinds of alt-right and super
conservative i saw somebody saying
welcome james
i i appreciate the love no
so the funny thing is though it's like i
even got an email the other day
from some fool saying that like i didn't
really get my degrees
from the colleges that i claim i got
them from conservative bible college or
something like that and it's like
what in the world is going on um no
uh i actually fall pretty far
i mean my ideal i felt pretty far to the
left so my ideal kind of government
set up if i had my way about it which i
probably
wouldn't because i don't like telling
people what to do um
would be very close to norway which is
you know not
exactly known as a uh
libertarian right-wing alt-right
neo-nazi bastian of the world it's you
know i would
i still think honestly if we want to get
to a specific kind of thing
i still think that the proper highest
income tax bracket should be probably
just around and maybe a little bit above
50 percent so it's not like i'm one of
these kind of contractionist small
government
you know drowning in the bathtub people
i'm certainly not conservative i'm not
socially conservative in any regard
like people can do whatever they want
like uh you know you want to have sex
with
with a banana being well wielded by a
clown and that makes you happy
good for you who am i to judge i don't
care there's quite a specific fantasy
you've got there mate
well it's one i use as an example i
write something from dan savage about
cakes and so it's like
you know i got to think of something
weird i just literally don't care but
but before we interrupt it's lovely to
see that you accept me mate
yeah see that's what it was really about
he does get called a banana quite
regularly but
i just wanted for people to know that
because i i felt like the way we started
the conversation
all right so yeah let's make it really
your european social democrat i think is
what yeah that's probably right most of
the people in my life who are on the
right call me a communist
which is historically false also it's
just as false as the fact that i'd be on
their i mean i'm
really not a communist but i do actually
believe
it i am a proper traditional liberal
who thinks that in in the in an advanced
democracy because of the nature of what
an advanced democracy is
you do have to have a very strong and
stable social safety net you do have to
have strong social insurance programs
you do have to in in the sense let's
just lay them out and
i'm very keynesian in the sense that i
think that that which the public sector
can do most efficiently and most
affordably the public sector should do
and the private sector should be able to
do what it does most efficiently
affordably in the point of economic
policy
discussion is to determine what the
boundaries on those things are
and to uh you know figure out which
thing goes in which box and how to how
to deal with it
um so yeah most of my positions are
pretty pretty staunchly
in the left they're just not in the
they're just not leftist
right just a different thing so so let
let's now turn now that we've got that
out of the way i felt it was important
for people to know that about you
let's turn to the mythology that you're
talking about because this is i think
really important i'm going to take a
little bit of time to set it out because
i think it's important so
the mythology that you were talking
about and do correct me
when you get the chance to to do that if
you need to
is the following society is
structurally injust against minorities
and women
and other oppressed groups and what that
means
is that different people are treated
differently in the same circumstances so
a black homeless man he's get gets
treated worse than a white homeless man
uh a woman who's a ceo
is treated less well or paid less than a
man who's a ceo etc etc
and as a result of that we have a
society that is structurally unfair
and what we need is uh a movement which
is called
social justice the point of which is to
address some of these hidden
instances of discrimination and indeed
the fact that all of us
are prone to discrimination particularly
those of us who are
from the traditionally speaking
privileged groups those of us that are
men
those of us that are white those of us
that are straight those of us that are
not trans
etc that's the mythology and
it's the notion of this myth is that we
must all
look to address the the the biases
within us
to make society better and fairer for
people who are
historically disadvantaged to eliminate
discrimination to make sure that people
are no longer oppressed
and to make sure the power is equally
distributed between the different groups
right now most people listening to that
actually i suspect would go well
there's an element of truth to that i
mean we're all we've all got prejudices
we're all probably a little bit racist
we might have inherited sexist
stereotypes from our parents and
grandparents
um society is a little bit unfair if you
you know police probably are sometimes
treating
black suspects harsher than white
suspect women have had it
uh bad over history uh you know slavery
was definitely an evil and that surely
would have left some sort of legacy
so if you're just an ordinary person
who's listening to this
um and going i see this guy on twitter
james lindsay
trying to take all this stuff apart like
you know if i'm an ordinary person why
should i
be why should i have a problem with
quote-unquote social justice
okay so you did a good job outlying or
laying out not outlying i don't know
what i'm talking about outlying counties
or something no
you did a good job laying out the um
very friendly although still not
without issue uh
understanding of the mythology you in
fact did a very good job of the social
justice aspect i would tell you that the
actual movement that we call maybe woke
or whatever is a com it's a combination
of
three schools of thought and one of them
is social justice
which is this kind of egalitarian thing
that so the mythology you laid out
it has a little bit of the critical
aspect but it's mostly what you laid out
was
one that's egalitarian and tipping
occasionally into a radical
egalitarianism
so that's one aspect but wokeness is
actually the intentional combination
of critical theory which has its own
mythology
post-modern theory which has its own
mythology
and doing those for the purpose of
creating social justice which has its
own mythology
and the the you have to understand that
when you just laid out like the
egalitarian picture that even tips into
the radical egalitarian picture here and
there meaning that yeah we really do
need to kind of
you know flip the script so
egalitarianism would be obviously that
everybody's
view gets taken seriously radical
egalitarianism would be
that we're going to make up for past
injustices or even current injustices by
forwarding people
extra to that have been historically or
are currently discriminated
we're going to take those people more
seriously than we otherwise would
and so you that's kind of the social
justice mythology when you said that you
know oh so there's
you know if you're straight you're white
you're male what you're talking about in
general these kind of
what are classified under the critical
theory school
of thought as oppressor classes
versus oppressed classes which would be
racial minorities sexual minorities
gender minorities and we can go as
judith butler one of their chief
theorists put it that exasperated etc
of identity categories so the critical
theory school we have to add that in
and the critical theory school has the
mythology that the world is separated
this comes actually from marx
so the world is separated into
stratified groups that's what you were
describing
and these groups this is the key
observation are actually in zero
sum conflict for the uh
access to resources and opportunities in
society there is no
everybody's ships rise together in the
in the critical theory view
there is instead the view that there is
a there is a
relatively permanent underclass that is
seeking liberation from its oppressors
who are the elite
status uh groups as history
wound on the elite status groups became
identity groups rather than
you know the actual societal illnesses
right so we go from marx which is
workers of the world unite overthrow
the bourgeoisie right and become
the owners of the means of production of
capital of whatever it is of power in
other words
you take the power that has been taken
from you historically
and you are now owners of it because
you've united as a group of oppressed
people
to fight off and defeat the oppressors
right and so the the view there
is that where marx was worried about the
means of
economic immaterial production the
critical theorists became more
interested in the means
of uh social cultural
information production so they became
very interested in things like
education faith media pop culture
elements of middle culture and saying
that those things were creating an
ideology to hold down
the proletariat to keep them in their
place and then that
later in the 1960s in particular 50s and
60s fragmented into being very specific
about identity politics
as say the civil rights movement the
united states started to reach a peak
the identity politics aspect became very
prominent
it was kind of present earlier than that
they became very prominent in the 1960s
and so it kind of changed into an
identity politics thing but the key
thing there is that there's been
with with critical theory there's a
shift in
ethics that you have to see everything
that occurs in the world through a lens
of does this
maintain oppression or does it provide
the access to liberation from oppression
there's the belief now that people are
brainwashed by society by the elite
narratives of society to accept and
internalize their oppression in a form
of false consciousness that they have to
be awakened from
so part of the critical mythology is
that everybody
doesn't know how to act in their best
interests and it's the job of the
critical theorists the awakened few
to go around in consciousness rays as
they call it and wake people up
so this mythology when you add in the
critical element includes the idea that
all the normal people out there are
asleep
that they're being brainwashed by the
powerful elites of society
to work against their own interests and
in the interests of the elites who are
going to continue to oppress them
and if you really cut down to the
original critical theorists
what liberation from oppression means is
liberation from anything that's not
communism
so the the oppression is that which is
not communism
and so you kind of have this huge
shift conceptually when you start
integrating the actual critical theory
side
of um the mythology into
the underlying social justice mythology
that you laid out correctly so now that
radical egalitarianism starts taking on
literally
mind reading that everybody has you know
internalized
the status quo and wants to maintain it
for selfish reasons
it needs to be awakened to how terrible
their lives are
so there's this new thought that only
the elites have a good life and
everybody else has a terrible life and
needs to be awakened to it because they
don't even realize it that's part of the
mythology
and that's where it's almost like the
influence of the devil is in everybody
comes into the picture
then and i know this is long and
complicated no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no just carry on keep going
it just is what it is then you get the
post-modern aspect
and post-modernists we're technically
not the same
kind of thing as a critical theorist if
we get really formal the critical
theorists
were called neo-marxists they were
looking at marxism in a new way they're
very critical of
old original marxism so they became
something different but they were
ultimately still marxist at heart
in terms of much of how they thought the
post-modernists
are classified as post-marxists they
were people they were french
philosophers for the ones that were
interested in who had basically seen
communism fail everywhere it was tried
and just went into this sort of despair
nothing can be good they also were being
french picked up with french philosophy
that was very
prominent at the time you know from the
from just
ahead of their time i should say which
would include existentialism so a lot of
nihilism came out of that
and then uh structuralism which was this
view
that the way that language is structured
leads to how people think and how people
will then build the power dynamics of
society so they got
very interested in language very
interested in knowledge very interested
in what they
categorize as discourses the underlying
discourses of society
started to form the structures by which
society is organized and power plays out
and power
operates uh in a dynamic way and so
what the post-modernists added to the
um mythology is that somehow
language how we speak about things what
we consider legitimate what we will
consider true and false
are somehow central to the organization
of material reality in our experience in
material reality
literally that we don't live in a
world where we have access to objective
you know or close to
objectively understanding the world we
can't do scientific experiments and
and really determine what's true uh
because
we are caught up in what michel foucault
called regimes of truth
that are political apparatuses at kind
of the super structural in the marxian
sense
at that level that dictate how people
are going to
decide to authenticate statements as
true or false so foucault's point a lot
of people don't understand this
is that whether or not a truth claim
is actually true is irrelevant it might
be
that's fine it might not be and that's
also fine because the point isn't that
the point of interest and relevance
is that there was a political process
that determined
somebody's ability to say that it's true
or false so if you say no no it's the
rigor of the experiment and the method
and
no well that was decided by a political
process too so for foucault it was
politics and power games all the way
down
and so humans just live in regimes of
truth that shape their views of reality
and so we we don't have direct access to
understanding anything outside of our
own lived experience
so now you have to shift away from being
able to know anything
and into the personal lived experience
of whatever it happens to be as being
the
genuine authentic experience of of the
world
you you that's foucault's view you can
look at derrida's view we don't have to
get deep into jack darida but
his general point was that meaning
cannot actually be confer
conveyed properly in language uh words
like if i say something like you know
zoom meeting or
computer or microphone or tree things
that i'm actually looking at right now
that those words don't actually refer to
those things at all in
any in any intelligible way they only
refer
to the words that they are related to
either in direct fashion so if i say
something like
you know maple because the trees outside
my window are maples
if i say maple that word's related to
tree that words related to plant that
word's related to life that words
related you know we can get on and on
but then also in terms of how words are
related by not being a thing so a tree
is say not a bush and a bush or a plant
is not an animal
and so all meaning is just caught up in
the relationships between
words and his claim having drawn off of
the structuralist school
was that power is hidden in those
relationships those relationships
between words are the discourses
they dictate how words gain meaning but
what this is is actually a removal of
meaning from language
and and so you can't use language to
derive stable meaning
and these two ideas combine to a new
aspect of mythology that
um our friend mike nena refers to as a
metaphysics of discourse
so now it's that the way we speak about
things the way that's considered
legitimate to speak about things
actually shapes what is and is not true
and that's actually a political process
and so the the outgrowth of post-modern
mythology
is that literally everything is politics
and so since literally everything is
politics it's all a matter of whose
politics are on the right side of
history versus who's
on the wrong side of history and matters
like truth and falsity
well they're not technically irrelevant
they're way down the list of importance
so that you can then pick and choose
what we see with wokeness
is a deliberate combination of the
critical theory mythology
with this aspect of post-modern
mythology about knowledge and truth and
language and meaning
so that you could use post-modern theory
to deconstruct systems of power
but not to deconstruct the lived
experience of oppression which is
considered properly basic now because
that's where they move everything so you
have this
much more elaborate mythology where
literally and this is the post-modern
contribution literally the words that we
use the way that we think what we
consider true
infects us and makes us literal agents
of the oppression that the critical
theory school sees
or if we learn to take the right
discourses up
literal agents of liberation and so who
we happen to be
politically not in terms of say your
skin color
being black isn't enough you have to be
politically black being gay is not
enough you have to be politically queer
when you take up the right politics your
identity itself
which is where your lived experience is
becomes
the the epistemological forward claim
and so that's a
long ride away from that nicer
but still a little bit like there's some
questions in that you know mythology of
social justice that you laid out
all right so just to put that all into
simple language what you're really
saying is
we have been told or some people have
been convinced
that we are in a battle
between groups of people one of which is
good and one of which is bad right
and we have no
there is no truth there is only a battle
over words
and if you whoever wins that battle is
the one that
that gets to determine what the truth is
and the argument is that the powerful
bad groups have been determining what
the truth is by abusing language
therefore what must now happen is we
must agree that there is no truth
other than what i feel and if i feel
that you are oppressing me by staring
directly into the camera
and i am from a minority group and
you're a straight white man
that means you are oppressing me right
that's exactly right the
in that last part so important that the
hierarchy
of identity which is really rooted in
what's called ethno-historicism
so identity combined with how that
identity has been treated both presently
but more importantly historically
determines the valence of what
directions oppression can operate
in so dominant groups i could never if
i'm
you know labeled as a member of a
dominant group relationally to you
i could never claim oppression uh
because i
you can't possibly oppress me because
oppression requires systemic power
right so 10 people from my group were to
chase you down in the street because of
your skin color and beat you up
uh and call you a white whatever that
still wouldn't be oppression that would
be that's what it is
exactly because there's no systemic
power so the kind of mythological object
is systemic power
as it has been literally crystallized in
the so-called matrix of domination
laid out you know in the foundational
documents of intersectionality in 1990
um and it's set up so that that
can't change because there's always the
constant appeals to
either a history or b that structuralist
idea or post-structuralist idea from the
from the post-modern school that
says that when you create a culture
until you completely overthrow that
culture all of its
biases and political power and all of
those things are baked into the
discourses
so we could have a system where we're
literally under the boots
of the most radical um say black lives
matter activists that represent maybe
one percent of the population in terms
of their views i mean genuinely radical
people who don't represent almost
anybody in terms of what they think
and yet everybody that they genuinely
oppress would not be able to consider
themselves oppressed
because they would have an appeal to say
well the system we still have to operate
in was generated by cultural moors that
were generated in white
western european contexts all right
francis now i'd like you to please
summarize what james has been talking
about in three sentences go
well to me to me it just proves my
number one rule of life which is you
should never trust the french but anyway
so uh but what i wanted to ask you james
is this so
what we've done is is we've analyzed the
structure the the way that it works the
thought processes
i'm very interested in the emotions
behind this now we talk about mythology
mythology had a purpose two thousand
years ago to explain
things that at that time we had no
concept of
or an understanding of why certain
things happened why they wrote why the
sunrise white set all the rest of it
why do we have this mythology now
i think it's actually because whereas
the physical sciences have matured quite
successfully so we understand why the
sun rises and why the sun sets
the social sciences have not the social
sciences are still
quite opaque the methodologies are not
worked out we don't know what rigorous
looks like
the uh rising replication crisis
especially in social psychology has
shown
that the methods that we believed in
were very easy to hack and to create
lots of uh you know successful papers
uh out of out of thin air more or less
and so the social sciences are in their
infancy
that doesn't get to the the emotional
side of it but the social sciences are
in their infancy so they're not
actually well developed very mature
uh lines of reasoning so in a sense the
social process is how power
actually works in society when we
started at the beginning talking about
how these narratives run away from us
that's something that the
post-modernists would been very
interested in it's very closely related
to post-modern theory
and so in general what we've seen and we
can get to the emotions in a second with
this
what we've seen through history is that
there's kind of
mythology leading into natural
philosophy or really philosophy leading
into natural philosophy
leading into science and so what we have
is kind of a hardening up from mythology
into philosophizing where now reason
becomes more important that hardens up
into let's look at the world
to base our reason to let's actually use
experimentation and falsification
and get really hard rigorous methods and
it turns out that a
human beings and human thought are very
complex and then human social behavior
is of course another order of complexity
higher than that
so it's very difficult it's not like
tracking a baseball shot out of a cannon
or something like that you know with a
projectile motion physics equation or
figuring
out you know how we're going to even
send a rocket to the moon these are very
straightforward calculations using
relatively
hard but relatively simple underlying
formulas
it's hard math but it's the principles
aren't so
social sciences are much more complex
and so we we have this problem
where we're still quite early on and
the so we're moving from
mythology and if you look at say freud
freud was very even jung you're talking
like those are considered the
forefathers of psychology this is a
hundred years ago and
they were very mythology
like there was that was just the very
beginning of bringing philosophy into
the picture
of the social sciences and it's just a
hundred years ago and it's such a
complex subject
and now you know you might say that
we're we're in this weird phase where
there's some of its philosophy
that like ethics some of it is natural
philosophy where we're very closely
looking at the world
and some of it is you know closer to
hard science where people are being very
rigorous and there's this kind of
spectrum of rigor
happening and in the process of this
first of all a lot of it's not working
out a lot of it's not giving us the
answers when we try to do
experiments like the great society where
we're going to now base
our societies on social scientific
research but the social scientific
research is really early on you're going
to make some bad mistakes and it doesn't
work out and people are going to get
upset
but there's a second process happening
besides all of this confusion from a
nation
scientific process we might be still
even with the advent of ai which will be
i think
necessary to understand psychology and
sociology properly
even with the advent of that we might
still be 100 or 50 years away from a
robust social science
a properly rigorous one but in addition
to this this shift
from um you know mythology through
philosophy to more natural philosophy to
actual science
this never ever ever ever progresses
without the people on the weaker end of
that epistemologically without them
losing their [ __ ]
the turf wars get insane so what you
actually see is this rise of the
prominence of the social scientists and
then you have these people who are
closer to
philosophers uh working in humanities
departments
gender studies for example ethnic
studies african american studies
these people don't have the slightest
idea about doing statistics they don't
have the slightest interest in doing
statistics
and uh they become jealous if you read
back cp snows the two cultures you can
see that there's this
great jealousy between the philosophy
side of things and the science side of
things is that
that transition happens because
basically the philosophers who
held themselves in high esteem and had
good elite jobs become pretty much
irrelevant they're just people sitting
in an armchair making [ __ ] up
and the scientists are finding out the
real truths of the world and nobody
likes that when you you know they're the
one getting excluded
and so there's actually been in this
kind of this combination of it lacking
success
in the the application realm and then
in the sense that it's still so new but
you have the humanities people
losing prestige there was a push back
for the humanities
and and philosophy types to gain
prestige and
they actually went backwards rather than
applying rigorous philosophy they
started to build a more and more
mythological structure
and i think the reason for that on top
of their envy and hatred of the sciences
that are stealing their
their importance um and their inability
to produce
reliable results rigorously and be taken
seriously on top of that there's the
the problem that because they've adopted
these ideas like conflict theory from
marx and these ideas about
you know these kind of very simplistic
ideas about how individuals operate
within the context of identity
categories
when you have something that's not true
the only thing that you can really do is
start to lean more and more heavily
on the force of story and they decided
to lean
straight into that and started to con to
create
a very mythological view if you follow
like in our books
helen and i just grow it's about to come
out cynical theories we actually
talk about that in a sense which is
that um over the years we just focus on
post-modernism but over the years since
the 1960s when post-modernism came into
the picture
what you actually see is something that
was very complex
first getting packaged up so activists
could use it and then becoming very
simple and concrete so that when you
read somebody like robin d'angelo who
obviously is a huge
rock star figure right now in the field
it literally comes off like she's
like a 10 year old could read it it's
very simple it's very straightforward
it's very condescending
and that's because um the the
oversimplification
and and and kind of dogmatic
authoritarianism the the
the mythological backing becomes
the thing that makes up for the fact
that they don't have rigor so there's
this
rather than them saying oh i'm going to
learn statistics and try to do this
right
they just you know went the other way
and started to say statistics
is part of the evil in the world and so
we're going to avoid that on principle
and and call it a master's tool and
you know become more story driven etc
and so there's this really weird
um kind of retrograde
development and the failure of social
science to
to be rigorous enough and to have this
replication crisis and so on coming into
into the picture
led there to be a lot of room for well
obviously the the scientist people don't
really know what they're talking about
so
we'll tell a story that fills that in
and i think that's what happened
and james and i know there's another
question i wanted to ask is because
it seems to be the younger generations
who seem to be
you know infected and believing these
narratives
why do you think that it's the younger
generation in particular
and not the older generations as a
result is it because of the college is
it because
at that age you simply know less
therefore you tend to be more malleable
or is it because more and more
young people are realizing that the
capitalism they're being exposed to
isn't really working for them when it
comes to things like home ownership
the gap between rich and poor etc etc
yes it's all of those things it is
actually all those things so
this kind of like pernicious and cynical
analysis has
this the critical theory analysis has
actually been a fundamental part of
primary secondary and university
education now for
a number of years for whatever set of
reasons our schools decided to focus in
at least in the united states on
self-esteem initiatives rather than
accomplishment initiatives
and this has created people that weren't
you know if you read like jonathan
height and greg lieutenant
you see that this is this has created um
individuals who are not as resilient
and not as capable of dealing with um
their lack of understanding of the world
so when you have your you know normally
young people are very
like just becoming sort of i guess
politically conscious and
they get caught up in these things um
and
then you can add in to what you said all
the things you said i don't really have
to repeat them
uh but you can add into this one extra
element
which is a general loss of
meaning in a society that's bent on the
idea of progress
and why i say that is because while
you have you have this confluence of
events where things are definitely not
perfect and there are definitely
observable problems
say with regard to race with regard to
sex with regard to
trans issues and so on and so forth
they're definitely observable problems
stuff isn't
figured out and perfect some of the
stuff may never be perfect
but at the same time the big civil
rights battles were actually already
fought and
those are kind of the big heroes of our
of our time you know that's
two generations removed from from the
world today
and so the big heroes we look back to
were the civil rights giants oh you know
we made life better for black people and
that was like the greatest thing
possible martin luther king is
and i do think that of course martin
luther king did insanely good work and
some of the most important work in the
history of
the western world but at the same time
you get a bunch of people hop
young people hopped up on this vision
that creating civil rights success
is the big thing to do and then the
battles are like
well do you like add an extra bathroom
for trans people like what do you do
like it's it's like because the whole
trans thing came out and people are like
some people are trans and everybody was
kind of like okay
like there was no fight there was no
drama it was just they had to make
fights about bathrooms and sports
which genuinely create you know there
are genuine issues there
but for the most part it's like well be
trans if you want
it's like i remember with one of my kids
like she went through this whole series
of different
changes you know we were all atheists
and so all of a sudden she became
christian
and she was like i'm a christian now and
we're like okay you want me to go to the
store and buy you a bible and she was
like
you didn't get mad at me that proves you
don't love me and it's like
okay you know you're a 14 year old girl
aren't you
and then it was like then it was like
i'm bisexual and we're like
yeah we kind of always thought that and
then she's like ah
you didn't try to disown me you don't
really love me and it's like it's just
you know there's been so much successful
civil rights progress
that when these new civil rights issues
come up there are
like with the trans issue around say
bathrooms and around
sports and around a handful of other
kind of concerns there are specifics
that have to be figured out and worked
out and that are actually genuinely
difficult in that case
fine but
in the principle everybody's like yeah
okay expand rights oh yeah
gay people normal okay and so there's
there's this burning need
in the young people to be civil rights
heroes
there's visible problems of imperfection
and then the really like profound and
meaningful fights
are easy so there's no meaning in it
you're like we're here for gay rights
and everybody's like okay have a parade
cool like let's set that up you know
it's like there's not
nobody shows up with fire hoses or
anything like this
and so they're looking for a big fight
but no one wants to fight them back
nobody needs to fight yeah so it's like
and that genuinely does create a crisis
of meaning and then if you couple that
with what
which said francis where um if you
couple that with
the fact that the world genuinely
especially like
post 2009 recession and financial crisis
and then whatever the universities have
been doing to these poor kids
i don't mean mentally i mean financially
like they're properly screwed
and so you tie into that level of like
resentment that the society has
cheated them and stolen from them and so
you have this kind of very
a bunch of friends actually who are like
bernie people and they don't like the
woke
at all and they think that the woke is
like totally excessive and insane
but they're like 100 occupy wall street
and they're just mad as hell that occupy
wall street didn't work and the
republicans are stealing our future from
us and these big business interests and
the corrupt
corrupt politicians are stealing our
future from us and there's like a lot of
kind of truth to that
and then now after this is all blown up
they don't know what to do because it's
like
they kind of they're like well the woke
are busting everything up so we're on
their side now even though we don't like
them
you know and so there's this weird like
fight but they don't know where the real
fight is and then there's an issue
that's gaining traction so they latch on
to it and get get all worked up
it's a very confusing time i think to be
under 35
not least because the schools have
literally been mindfucking them pretty
much the entire time so that they think
in weird poisonous
ways to find where you know oppression
and bad things are happening and to not
trust the system or
understand how the system works and so
on so really like so
when you ask the question you listed a
bunch of stuff it's like yes
it's a bunch of stuff at once and james
we're now hit this catalyst which is
covered
we have now seen the black lives matter
movement we've now seen
you know writing you know destruction of
property
and it's very very it's a it's a tricky
question to watch
hold on before you say writing we
learned yesterday that the proper term
is in intensified peacefulness
okay that means rioting and arson
yeah courthouse burned down as a
literally the the the news report said
um
the courthouse got burned down and
something else was badly damaged and
police officers were injured when a
peaceful demonstration
intensified yeah so it the peacefulness
intensified as a result of which
property got destroyed and people got
injured that's right so we've seen a lot
of peacefulness francis is what you were
saying
yeah mate i yeah i i i burnt uh
uh the dinner last night so i saw some
intense first
intensified peacefulness at last night's
dinner but anyway
uh the point is james is where do you
think this is gonna
end up do you think what do you think is
a natural progression for this
that's hard and scary every people keep
asking me this and it's like oh it's so
non-linear
i wish you would just ask me the easy
question like what's their end goal
and it's like i don't think they have
one but somebody that's behind them
probably does
so we'll see who tries to scoop up like
i'm starting to get the impression that
the woke are the useful idiots for
somebody who's not as
not as uh politically lost and
internally contradictory
and they are basically the bulldozers
leveling the ground so that some
somebody who actually wants to build
something scary in the world can come in
and fill that space
but uh i don't know for sure what will
happen
now uh i think a lot of people have
have been awakened to wokeness and many
of them are
the liberal type who need to fight back
against it with reason
and trying to claim
the mantle of moral and epistemological
authority
and and high ground that that comes with
that and
to fight for putting our society back on
the track
of genuine you know proper progress
but at the same time there is what
people kind of refer to as the sleeping
giant and last time
we spoke we you asked about this when we
actually talked about it we talked about
whether or not there was going to be a
rise of genuine racism a rise of genuine
sexism
and that's the sleeping giant which is
our majority groups going to be awakened
to
full bear um
zero sum identity politics and i
genuinely think at this point that the
giant is stirring and has one eye open
and that's a bad place to be so
no reasonable person wants this the
wokes game is to claim that there's no
such thing as a reasonable person
so everybody who is against them does
want that
and that's ridiculous which is why the
three of us are all all right and blah
blah blah because you can't oppose them
without being smeared and tarnished
so that no reasonable person can oppose
them because
therefore all reasonable people would
agree with them
right that's because of the mythology
which the first tenet
of which if it's the critical race
mythology says that racism is the
ordinary state of affairs in our society
not aberrational
and so that translated into robin
d'angelo condescending speak is the
question is no longer did racism take
place but how did racism manifest in
that situation because the racism is to
be assumed
so um that's part of the mythology that
racism is in every possible interaction
if you look at just that aspect
so if that infects
the sleeping giant and the sleeping
giant wakes up and you start to see
these like
militia groups going crazy
or white identity politics rising
i don't see any solution other than
civil war
which will be a very nasty one because
that's the thing that's very hard to
stop once it starts happening
it's very hard to get that resentment
and anger back under control
and the woke have the narrative on their
own side
that that resistance is to be expected
resistance is a predictable result
of doing this work blah blah so they
think that they're genuinely
unmasking people who are always
alt-right
you know evil racist lunatics and
they'll use it as evidence
so you see this happening in these
cities in america these protesters know
what they're doing they're not idiots
they actually know what they're doing
they're objective when they go on
agitated say a federal building in
portland last night
their objective is to try to get law
enforcement to react
their goal is to try to get the police
or even better the feds
to step in and try to control them at
which point if it's the police to say
look fascists and if it's the feds
they'll say
trump is now seizing power he's the
dictator that we've been telling you he
is for four years
and it's this weird thing where there's
enough people who believe that narrative
and this is that relevance of that
trumped arrangement that i was talking
about
that when they say it a huge proportion
of left-leaning under-35s are all going
to believe it yep that's it
um my friend for example recently got
very upset with me my bernie one of my
bernie friends and he said
you know what do you think's going on
and i told him and he just got really
mad at me and then said you've shot your
arrow and painted the target around it
and i was like okay conversation over
um if that's how you're gonna think
about this uh
fine but that's kind of what's going on
it's like you literally have people who
are so convinced that trump is a
dictator in waiting
and i will admit there are concerning
signs there are concerning possibilities
around that
claim um
uh the the so with his the most
concerning one for me
has nothing to do with his policy it's
the kind of like
a loyalty based attempt to fill his
government
only with people who are loyalists to
his cause right so there's like these
purges happening within different
government departments to try to get
them on site
that stuff makes me concerned his
policies
not so much he's not even really like
gone nuts too much with the executive
orders or any of these kind of things
he's not doing anything overtly like
that but when you start trying to make a
purity campaign within your own
government rather than
a ideological diversity campaign that's
a different thing well isn't that
isn't that just a businessman's way of
doing things and if you run a business
you don't want people who fundamentally
disagree with them
oh sure sure the mission statement of
your business right so something being
concerning isn't the same as something
being
proved right so there are there are
signs that it's possible
i genuinely think it's unlikely that
trump is actually
dictatorial in his and his uh ambition
it's more likely that he's
dynastic and trump wants to try to rig
the system so that say his kids become
president next and you know
there's this kind of that wouldn't be
all that unusual for the united states
let's be honest
no kidding do we need another bush or
clinton to come in and save the day
right maybe a couple roosevelts or
something all right james
look just to wrap up it's an interesting
it's a fascinating not just interesting
it's fascinating talking to you about
this but i want to make
for last five ten minutes of the
interview just turn this
right into the real world which is
people are now starting to see we've had
it in this country
people being fired for criticizing them
this movement
people being ostracized what's called
cancel culture
uh people a lot you know 62 percent of
americans now say in the latest cato
poll that
they are scared to express their
political opinion publicly
46 of people in britain
say that they we we have less free
speech
uh than we did a few years ago versus 20
that say we have more
so the direction of travel is this
movement has taken hold
of all the cultural institutions the
education system
television news media etc people are
feeling it
and if someone is watching the show and
and they've
they've sat through 40 minutes of us
talking about critical race theory and
foucault
and they're going okay well i feel all
this is happening
around me what the hell do i do
right so unfortunately there's not like
oh you know go register with this and
you're done you know
and it's hopefully not so grim as learn
chinese um
but i mean but the the the long and
short of what you
you actually do have to put in some leg
work if you want to do something there
are two options
do you want to take it on or do you want
to do something different and both of
those things are
success vectors the if you want to take
it on
you have to learn some of it you have to
the stuff that we just talked about you
have to become at least
basically conversant in it you have to
learn to see
the word games the the setups
because that's what these are it's built
out of setups i've said it over and over
and over again just as a very quick
idea uh but this will come into every
context in your life with say critical
race theory it assumes racism is in
everything
therefore say you run a shop and a white
person and a black person enter at the
same time you have to pick one customer
to help first
if you pick the white person the racism
must be present and so the
the reason you pick the white person is
because you think white people are
first-class citizens and black people
are second-class citizens and you're a
racist
you pick the black person first it's
because you don't trust black people to
be unattended in your store while you
help the other customer
then you want to get them out of your
stores quickly as possible and you're
racist because racism must be present in
every situation so when you start to see
that the thing is playing a game with
you to set you up to keep you on your
heels to make you feel stupid to make
you feel immoral to make you feel like
you're on the wrong side of history to
make you feel like you're not part of
what where the crowd is going
you once you see that then you can find
your own feet but you do have to learn a
little bit about how the
ideology thinks how it uses language
what it means by its words there's a
little bit of leg work put it to put
into that
i made new discourses to provide
resources for that
you can use it you can use other ones
i'm not like i'm the only correct voice
on this or people speaking up it's good
so um you have to learn something
and then you have to start talking with
other people find people who agree with
you start to organize and actually start
showing up
if you're going to be an activist you
have to show up activists show up that's
why these people are in so many
like bureaucracies they're on so many
committees they're installing policies
and that's where it's happening is
they're changing the level
they're changing the world at the level
of administrative policy so that people
are stuck having to behave
or they'll get fired or something like
that so you have to show up and push
back the other way get on the committee
volunteer with your boss to help lead
you know the diversity leadership
initiative that you everybody has to
take up now and try to steer it away
from this nonsense and toward more
productive
venues so that you can tackle the real
problems on the other hand
if you're like i can't learn like uh
a lot of a lot of my even very smart
friends very academic friends like i
just
can't think like that i can't think
wrong
stuff okay great you maybe you should
learn a little bit of it
just to have some background do what you
can don't stress
what you actually need to do you do need
to understand the way that it does shake
downs on people but other than that you
need to go build the thing
go build the thing if it's in our
schools people need alternatives they
need other ways to get educated to
educate their kids
and the united states is going to be an
ungodly number of people doing
homeschooling those people are going to
need
resources they're craving the reason
they're doing the homeschooling is they
want
not woke resources educational resources
so go build a thing that offers that
if you're going to work you know in law
you know leave your current law society
if it's going vocal go create one that
isn't
and you know don't put like proudly
racist since 2020 on the side
but you know proudly not woke is
actually a thing right now you know
you know you'd have to find the right
wording obviously no but totally i know
what you mean i said this
the other day like if you if your small
business comes under attack from these
work people now the best thing you can
do
the best thing you can do right now is
just double down and go
my mars bars are for non-work people and
you're gonna get
way more money than you would have done
otherwise it's absolutely true
um so people who
are looking at this world do need to
understand
that giving into this will not satisfy
the problem it's
it is an unsatisfiable black hole of a
problem
giving in to something that's shaking
you down or extorting you is an
invitation for them to shake you down or
extort you again later
and that's really what this is it's
using
using
fancy terminology a claim on the current
of history
and agitations about people's moral
standing
rather than say physical intimidation to
bully them it's using administrative
policies to try to get people fired
so uh yeah build the thing go build the
thing we're going to be a company that's
not going to be woke
we're going to get harassed and we're
going to endure the harassment to give
people
a place they can work and if you're
going to build a company you will
out-compete your competitors because
they're going to have to
divert an increasing amount of resources
to wokeness if they let it into their
company because it's not satisfiable
it just keeps coming for another
shakedown another
as you know it's very mafia logic it's
like kicking the
kicking it up to the to the to the mob
boss and so
do the thing we need like if we if you
say oh my gosh everything's fallen
there's two ways to look at that that's
you know chicken little the sky has
fallen or whatever and there's
this is an opportunity and i'm about to
about to blow this thing up
so just if you don't want to learn this
and take it on head-on you don't want to
be an activist
just go do the thing and like you said
stand strong double down
you this is what so i know your last
question is coming
it was the thing that nobody's talking
about i'm gonna steal your thunder and
just jump right to it go for it [ __ ]
psych
take that francis take that i got my
banana for you right here
i thought you'd never ask mike yeah no
but no that's the thing is
nobody's talking about the fact that the
liberal perspective the one that we've
built
our modern world out of has the moral
high ground
it is it is the right way to think about
these issues it's not to say that it's
perfect it's not to say that we can't do
better at listening or whatever else
but it holds the moral high ground it
has the also epistemological high ground
because it actually gives a [ __ ] what's
true
which is a different i mean you read
this paper allison bailey
2017 something about pro i can't
remember the title tracking privilege
preserving epistemic pushback
something shadow texts and philosophy
classrooms or some [ __ ] like this
and in there she literally writes that
epistemic adequacy
is a master's tool
epistemic adequacy is academic speak
for knowing what you're talking about
that's all like
literally knowing what you're talking
about is racist i'm pretty racist
sounds racist so you have the high
ground to say no
and nobody's talking about that
everybody's kind of like how do we make
them happy
you don't you don't you say no i'm
actually in the right here i talked to a
guy the other day and he's you know we
had a conversation like two hours in a
podcast and he's like
at the end he's just kind of sitting
there and he gets this look on his face
and he's like i think i've just come to
the point where somebody's gonna say you
know
hey you're racist and i'm just gonna say
no
no i'm not okay i'm not and that's it
like you do so if you want to ask me the
question i'll make up another one by the
way though
yeah i'm gonna do it purely out of spite
jake
with your smile that hides all your
spite your mask is slipping
yeah i'm nothing if not work so
uh what is the one thing that we're not
talking about that we really should be
do you mean like everybody because i
could just say like that the lay's dill
pickle potato chips are like next level
good
nobody talks about that i never hear
anybody say that at all
yeah they did well okay now two people
are saying it and then we have a skeptic
no um
so what i don't hear
people talking about that i think
people do need to talk about is regular
stuff
like not being political for once
regular stuff
like i know that they're trying to cram
it i saw the opening of the baseball
season it's like everybody's on their
knees and
crying in the field or something and
they got black lives matter on the
on the home run fence and all this crap
and it's like
but nobody's just talking about the
baseball game nobody's talking about
always going to work and just talking
about how to do the job nobody's talk
what is what are we not talking about
that we should be normal stuff
everyday stuff like getting together
with your family and not having a
political argument and just talking to
each other as human beings without the
politics injected
so i know that some people are doing
this but what we really all need to be
doing is ratcheting down
how much we're obsessing about what's on
the news how much we're obsessing about
what's on social media
how much we're obsessing about the
political valence of this the political
valence of that
and remembering that we can just be
normal people with each other
also and that that's really where life
is
right that's the heart that's the
beating heart of social life
these i might swear [ __ ] woke idiots
piss me off
because they're like we need to have
authentic cross-racial relationships by
focusing on the most divisive possible
thing in the relationship constantly and
bringing it up and calling each other
out
that's the least authentic way to have a
relationship
ever the most authentic way to have a
relationship is for me to look you in
the eye and say you're a person
that i can relate to you can look me in
the eye and say you're a person you
wouldn't really say that it's weird
but where people they can relate to each
other and let's just be
friends on terms that have something to
do with our lives
and let's not turn this into like a
political argument so
the thing that people aren't talking
about but should be is everything else
everything that's not what they're
yelling about on twitter that day
that's a really good point james and
i've been trying to say this to people
for some time now it's like
racism doesn't diminish because you got
admonished on tv
by somebody it diminishes when
people meet in the same space and
connect and find
out about each other's background and
culture and and and just
to connect as people and talk about
family and movies and
play sports together and do stuff
together when when they actually take a
moment
to not think about race to not think
about any of that stuff
and just connect as human beings um and
it's it's a really important point you
make
very bad for trigonometry yeah but but
don't listen to what james said
basically guys
yeah listen everybody watch trigonometry
and send them money
that's that's what you really that's
nobody's talking about your patreon
right well fortunately some people are
fans are helping us find a new studio
after we lost
our previous one not to be due to not
being quite woke enough but james listen
it's been an absolute pleasure
uh people should definitely definitely
check out cynical theories the the book
that you've just written
with heather uh helen platford is not
happy i do it all the time my wife's
name is heather and it's just a
nightmare i'm
mixing them up in my head all the time
well that that there's an extra
dimension to that that we're not
not as people just the names i'm very
clear on who's who
yeah uh so uh with the helen pluckross
he's a former guest of ours as well
also people should check out new
discourses they should follow you on
twitter if they do want to
to hear more about all this crazy race
stuff
and uh is there anything else that you
you want people to know about that you
do
um no that's pretty much all i do now uh
but i did
if people are are listening and you know
whatever i actually got
i bought a domain name
cynicaltheories.com so you don't have to
remember
like go look up cynical theory you can
actually cynical theories.com
just redirects to the amazon link now so
now you can just go buy it no problem
i don't think it works in the uk though
i think it's the us one you can only put
one
all right okay perfect before we finish
i've got very one last important
question what was the name of those
potato chips again
lay's dill pickle laze is the brand
pickle flavor
they are the perfect amount of dill
pickle flavor and vinegar and salt
it's like salt and vinegar but better
with the dill it's great stuff but
francis you're not getting anywhere near
crisps for the rest of your life mate
you're on a diet
yeah get in shape man he actually did
during the lockdown this is the thing i
used to
make fun of him for being fat and now
he's not fat oh very good
it's kind of disappointing disappointing
but anyway james thanks so much for
coming on the show it's been an absolute
pleasure make sure you check out
cynical theories and uh the news
discourses website
as well and it's been a pleasure
speaking with you enjoy
the rest of your day if you are in the
middle of a day enjoy evening if you're
in the evening and we'll see you very
soon with another
brilliant episode or a live stream
absolutely and our episodes and live
streams go out on tuesday wednesday
thursday friday saturday
and sunday always at 7 pm uk time at 7
p.m
uk time see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word